The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hello, and
welcome to 5.07 Biochemistry
on MIT OpenCourseWare.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
This series of videos
is meant to supplement
some of the other
materials on the site,
and to give you a more in-depth
and more interactive take
on some of the topics
covered in 5.07 Biochemistry.
Specifically, we're going
to be working together
through one problem from each
problem set from this course.
Today we're discussing the very
first homework problem of 5.07,
which is problem one
of problem set one.
This problem is
meant to give you
a better sense of the
scales and dimensions
of the cellular environment.
Specifically, we're going
to be asking questions
like, how big is this cell?
What is the volume of a cell?
And how many molecules
of a given protein
are inside a cell?
One fundamental idea
introduced in this problem
is that the cellular
environment is very crowded.
Things inside the cell
are very tightly packed.
Now take a look at this
picture in your book.
As you see here, the
constituents of a cell,
like proteins, enzymes, the
organelles, metabolites,
are all in very close
proximity to each other.
Now, this is also reflected
in the concentration
that we're given for the
proteins inside the cell.
The problem tells us
there are 350 milligrams
per milliliter of protein.
Or in other words,
350 grams per liter.
Now this is a very high number
in the context of biochemistry.
Basically, if you
think one liter
is 1,000 grams then 350
grams of that is protein.
So we have 350 grams,
35%, of a cell is protein.
And only 60% to 65% is water.
Therefore, as the
problem says, when
we're doing in-vitro experiments
using dilute solutions
we rarely recapitulate
what actually
happens inside the cell.
Now how big is a mammalian cell?
As you will see, sizes
of cells in an organism
vary considerably.
At one extreme we have very tiny
cells like endothelial cells,
red blood cells.
These are very, very small.
On the other end, we
have reproductive cells,
like the egg, which is 100
to 200 microns in diameter.
Or even cells that can stretch
for centimeter, like the muscle
cells and certain nerve cells.
In this problem, we're going to
be dealing with the red blood
cells, one of the most
abundant cells in the body.
As you can see in this
very colorful picture,
a red blood cell can be
approximated by a cylinder 6
to 8 microns in diameter.
So knowing that, we can actually
calculate some dimensions
of the red blood cells,
such as the total volume
and their surface area.
Now here is a cylinder by which
we approximate a red blood
cell.
And let's say the cylinder
has the height, h,
and the radius, r.
From our problem we know h
is about 2 microns and r,
well we know the diameter
is 6 to 8 microns.
So r is going to be, let's go
with the middle, 3.5 microns.
Now as you remember
from geometry,
then the volume
of the cylinder is
going to be pi r
squared h, which
when we substitute
our units, we're going
to get about 77 cubic microns.
All right.
We'll come back to discussing
the units in a little bit.
Now the surface
area is just going
to be the area surrounding the
cylinder plus the two circles--
the top and the bottom.
So the two circles are 2 pi r
squared plus the surrounding
area is going to be 2 pi r h.
And that comes out to be
about 120.95 square microns.
Now how much is really
one cubic micron?
Let's try to relate it
to a unit that we're
more familiar such as liter.
Well, one milliliter is
actually one cubic centimeter.
One microliter is
one cubic millimeter.
Now, one cubic micrometer,
it's like a billion times
smaller than 1 microliter.
One microliter is already
a million times smaller
than a liter, so this is really
10 to the minus 15 liters
is 1 cubic micrometer.
Which is 10 to the minus
15 is the femto units.
It's like one femtoliter.
Now 77 femtoliters is an
incredibly small volume.
But as we'll see next
when we look at bacteria,
bacteria are even smaller.
Now, let's take a look
at a Staph aureus cell.
Now Staphylococcus aureus
is a very common bacteria
that we often find on our skin
or in our respiratory tract.
Now this is the same
bacteria that you
might have heard in
that acronym MRSA,
or Methicillin-Resistant
Staph Aureus.
Now, this MRSA is a
pathogenic bacteria
that can cause a lot of
problems in the hospitals
nowadays, because it
is resistant to most
of the antibiotics that we have.
Now, here's a picture
of Staph aureus.
As you can see, it's
a spherical cell.
And of course this pretty
purple color is added in.
This is just a electron
micrograph picture
of a colony of Staph
aureus bacteria.
So for it too we can
calculate the volume
of the cell and
the surface area.
If we assume Staph aureus
to be a sphere, of radius r,
we are told r is 0.6 microns.
Then we can calculate
the volume of the cell.
The volume is simply going
to be 4 pi r cubed over 3.
And if we plug-in
the numbers, we're
going to get 0.11
cubic micrometer.
Similarly for the
surface area, it's
a surface area of a sphere.
It's 4 pi r squared.
And the units come out
to 1.13 square microns.
Now 0.11 cubic microns.
And we said a cubic micron
is one femtoliters, like 10
to minus 15 liters.
So 0.11 cubic micrometers is
110 times 10 to minus 18 liters.
Now the prefix for 10
to minus 18 that's atto.
So it's 110 attoliters.
So this is an
incredibly small volume.
So by calculating the
volume and the surface
area of these cells,
we've essentially
answered part 1 and
part 2 of this problem.
Now next we're going to
explore the relationship
between the volume and the
surface area of the cell.
As you know from geometry,
the volume typically
varies with the
cube of the radius,
whereas the surface
area varies only
with the square of the radius.
Therefore, as the
radius of an object
increases the ratio of
surface area over volume
will decrease because the
volume increases quicker.
Now, this is exactly what
we observe with cells.
Therefore, for a red blood
cell surface area over volume
it's going to be 12,095 square
microns over 77 cubic microns.
That comes out to about
1.6 inverse microns.
Now for a Staph aureus cell,
surface area over volume
is going to be 1.13
square microns over 0.11
cubic microns.
That's approximately 10.
Why is this important?
It's because the
surface area of a cell
controls how fast molecules
can go in and out of the cell.
It essentially controls the flux
of molecules across the cell
membrane.
Now, if the surface area of
a volume is a large number,
it means the molecules
can access that volume
fairly quickly and efficiently.
But as you can see,
the bigger the cell,
the smaller the surface area
of a volume number becomes.
And therefore, for big cells
molecules will have a hard time
and will take a long time
to get inside the cell
or out of the cell.
That's why nature has designed
ways to transport molecules,
to make them achieve the right
concentration efficiently.
Now this is why, in
the case of bigger
cells, such as the eukaryotic
cells or mammalian cells,
in our case the red
blood cells, nature
has evolved transport
mechanisms by which
it can deliver small molecules
throughout the entire volume
of the cell.
One example of such
transfer molecules
is hemoglobin, which
is used to deliver
oxygen. This is what we're
going to take a look at next.
We are given that
hemoglobin constitutes
95% of the proteins in
the red blood cells.
So let's calculate the
concentration of hemoglobin
in a red blood cell.
Now let's start with the
average protein concentration
in the cell, which we
mentioned earlier, which was
350 milligrams per milliliter.
Now if 95% of this
is hemoglobin,
then the concentration
of hemoglobin
is going to be about 322
milligrams per milliliter.
Now I'm going to abbreviate
hemoglobin as Hb.
We're told that hemoglobin has
a molecular weight of 67,000
Daltons, which is another way
of saying 67,000 grams per mole.
So then the concentration
of hemoglobin
is going to be 322
milligrams per 67,000.
Grams per mole is the
same as milligrams
per millimole and
per milliliter.
The grams go away
and we get 0.0048.
It's going to be
millimole per milliliter
and that's the same
as mole per liter.
That's the molar concentration.
Or we can write
it 4.8 millimolar.
Now this is a pretty
important range
to keep in mind, because
the most abundant proteins
such as hemoglobin, are going to
be in the low millimolar range.
Most of the other
proteins are going
to be in the micromolar
range in a cell.
Now let's calculate how
many molecules of hemoglobin
we have in the red blood cell.
So we calculated before that
the volume of a red blood cell
is actually 77 femtoliters.
That's once again 77 times
10 to minus 15 liters.
Now we know in this volume the
concentration of hemoglobin
is 4.8 millimolar.
So we can calculate
the number of moles.
So the new number
of moles is going
to be the concentration
times the volume.
So we have 4.8 millimolar
times 77 times 10 to minus 15
liters equals--
now of course, millimolar--
we have to transform
this back into molar.
We have mole per liters.
The liters are
going to cancel out
so we're going to get moles.
And it's 369, or so, times
10 to minus 18 moles.
Remember 10 to minus
18 that's attomoles.
So 369 attomoles of hemoglobin
we have in a red blood cell.
Now we know one mole
contains the Avogadro
numbers of molecules.
So if you multiply this
with the Avogadro number,
we should get the actual
number of molecules.
So number of molecules is just
Avogadro number times number
of moles, and Avogadro number
is approximately 6.022 times 10
to the 23rd power,
so a gigantic number,
times 369 times 10
to minus 18 moles.
We're going to get about 2.2
times 10 to the 8 molecules.
Or in other words, this
is 220 million molecules.
So the problem was telling us
about a Google search in which
we came up for different numbers
and one of them was 2,000,
one of them was 200 million,
so obviously the answer we got,
220 million, is closer to
the 200-300 million molecules
that our Google search returned.
That's the answer for
that part of the problem.
Finally, let's see how the
size of a hemoglobin molecule
compares to the size of a cell.
We're told hemoglobin is
roughly spherical in shape,
with a diameter of
about 55 Angstrom.
Now as you recall from
Intro to Chemistry,
one Angstrom is 10 to
the minus 10 meters.
That's 0.1 nanometer.
So our radius here is going
to be half the diameter,
so it's 27.5 Angstrom
is 2.75 nanometers.
So the volume of a
hemoglobin molecule
is going to be 4
pi r cubed over 3.
And with plugging
in 2.75 nanometers.
So it's going to come up to
be 8.7 times 10 to the minus
eighth cubic microns.
Now, you remember the
volume of a red blood cell
was 77 cubic microns,
so if you look
at the relationship
between the two,
how many volumes of a hemoglobin
can we fit in a red blood cell?
Well, we just divide the
volume of the red blood cell
to the volume of the hemoglobin.
77 over 8.7 times 10
to the minus eighth.
Both are cubic microns.
And that gives us 8.8 times
10 to the eight molecules.
So this is 880 million
molecules of hemoglobin
would fit in the volume
of a red blood cell.
If only hemoglobin
would be in there.
Obviously this number
is an overestimation,
because when you're
packing spherical objects,
they're not going to pack
very tightly with each other.
And as we said, the shape is
only approximately spherical,
but nevertheless it's on
the same order of magnitude
as the 200- 300 million
molecules of hemoglobin
that we calculated earlier
based on the concentration.
So from both the volume
standpoint and concentration
standpoint we now
have calculated
how many molecules of hemoglobin
can fit in a red blood cell.
This result we just got actually
highlights a very important
take home message,
which is, if we
look at the molecular
and atomic scale,
it is as distant from
the cellular scale
as the cellular
scale is different
from the macroscopic scale.
Now if we take one
milliliter of blood,
we find a few billion red
blood cells inside it.
Now within each
red blood cell we
find hundreds of millions of
molecules such as hemoglobin.
That's it for this problem.
I hope you now have a
better sense of the sizes
and scales relevant for
biochemistry and cell biology
in general.
Keep in mind our discussion
of the surface area
to volume ratio and why as
the cell size gets bigger,
we need transport
mechanisms to make sure
the nutrients and
metabolites get to where
they need to go efficiently.
Also keep in mind some of
the concentration ranges
that we discussed,
as these will become
very important in understanding
the biological significance
of some of the
constants that we're
going to calculate for
enzymes later in the course.